Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Five Nights With 39
Now before you go on about me, y'know, playing another Five Nights at Freddy's fan game,
the only reason I'm playing this one is because, supposedly, it's funny.
And, I really, really enjoy the humorous takes on Five Nights at Freddy's, and I'm pretty sure - is he dabbing?
Is - is - is that guy - is that guy dabbing? *Yes he is Mark*
Wait, hang on... *mark dabs wonderfully*
I did it!  I dabbed.
Am I hip with the kids? *Who says hip?*
So, I'm gonna play this one.  Apparently there's like six nights of this.
Uh, Im just gonna play until it stops being funny, because
I really, REALLY like all the funny Five Nights at Freddy's fangames *signature goofy laugh*
(Reading ad) "Fuck you buddy!"
"Five Night... FNBF spoiler below... Haha I killed your kid in my last game, got a problem mate?"
"Come down to Fazbear Advert Studio!  Oh boy will I be responsible for all injury or dismemberment!"
Oh that's cool.
(Reads How-To-Play box) *kind of long..*
Awwwh!  That sounds adorable except for killin' that guys kid! - I think.
I have no idea how this is gonna go.  I've never even heard of the games from this developer, apparently he's made some other ones but -
39:I honestly did not think you'd turn up
39:Well, welcome to the advert studio
39: I dunno why it's here, I dunno why I'm a *bleep* Animatronic character
39: I mean it's - I swear to god I have no idea. I mean-
39: It's like someone pulled this idea out of their arse and crafted it in one week.
39: You know that's - I think that's basically what it is.
39: So. Apparently you are paralyzed. *confused Markimoo*
39: HAHA. So you can't move at all until 6 AM
39: Brilliant
39: Then you get to watch me run around the cameras. Doing my own thing.*Scratches ear?*
39: And I'll eventually 'pop in' and visit you, so... yea!
39: Yeah, yeah...
39: Yep, have a good night,  mate!
Markimoo: Okay
39: I'm coming
Mark: Thanks buddy!
39: *epic voice* This looks dangerous, this looks dangerous. *confuzled Mark*
Mark: What? (laughs) I can't see anything on here! Everything is just flashing lights! There's - OH -No
Mark: Tha Hell?
M: What is happening?! I have no idea! What's happening?!
M: Tell me a reason why?!
M: Why am I here? Hehe. Why can't I see the cameras?
M: Aw, it's like -
M: That's so weird. I can't click on the camera's that have-
I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING, number one!
And number two, I'm PARALYZED?!
Is that your fault or me?! I have no idea... this is...
M: I like it already-hehehe!
M: Aw, there's nothing to boop the nose of :(
Oh wait! Of course there is!
M: HE! ... HIM! ... ii - 39!
M: 87! ... Whatever his name is, I don't know.
*loud bang* *39 laughs evilly*
M: A'ight, thank you! Is that supposed to spook me?
M: Didn't work!
M: I'm un-spookable (Sure Markimoo)
...Did you know that? (Of course)
M: Can't be spooped (spooped?)
M: No matter how hard you try
M: So just try.
GIVE IT TO ME
M" KILL ME, I'M HERE!
...can't see shit...
39: BAH
*startled Mark*
M: OH- fucking god damnit
39: Gotchyaaa (thought you couldn't be spooped mark...)
39: Aboogeywoogeywoo~ Mother*beep*
*Marki laugh*
39: Aaawah! *unintelligible noises ...darn you... *high pitched* Don't touch my nose *whining*
*Mark laughs some more*
M: Did he say 'Aboogeywoogeywoo~'?
M: *laughing* I think he said 'Aboogeywoogeywoo~' *Yes he did and it was adorable*
M: Oh man, I LOVE that
M: OOOH tha's hilarious!
M: Oh man, I remember playing through all of the 'Five Nights at Frickboys' games
M: And, uh
M: Aw, it was soo funny
M: I still don't know why I can't see anything in here *static*
M: Nothin' to seeeeee
M: But, uh, I guess I just gotta wait here
M: I guess. I have no idea *No you don't.
M: So, I'll just ~skedaddly-waddly until he comes by~!
39: BAH! Gotchyaaa
M: Cool! Ya did! (intense voice) You sure got me!
39: This is the part where I drain power to make things very intense
M: Is it? Is it really? *giggling*
39: Aaawah! *unintelligible noises ...darn you... *high pitched* Don't touch my nose
*mark laughs*
*39 whining*
M: a-BOO!
M: BOO!
M: I'm gonna go my mom's technique!
M: ha-BU
M: BU~
Seems like I'm all alone here - BOO!
M: BOO
M: Anybody on here yet? Camera not workin'?
M: Nope, still not working. Okay.
M: Don't sneak on me. Ha-BUE!
M: Don't sneak on me. BOO~!
M: Maybe he's gone away for- WOO!
M: I guess I should just drop my guard and relax about all this cause there doesn't seem to b- BOAHHH!
M: Oh maybe it's nothin'! Maybe it's nothing! Maybe I should just take a nap
M: *yawns* I so tiiired ( nice time for nap..)
M: BOO!
39: (so startled) BAH!
39: Gotchyaaa
M: Got you too
M: Hello
M: You just gonna stand there? That all you do?
M: Jus' stand there? Stand there and talk?
M: Habee!
M: Oh no! I got yer nose! Now run away you little... baby
M: I know it's the first night, so there's gotta be more stuff that comes near by, but this is actually just really funny.
M: Like even - what's the point - what is the point of even checking the lights?
M: What's the point of checking the camera when there's nothing here?
M: I mean I know it glows green. But that's just where it is. And these camera's are disabled or something?
M: And there's nothing there anyway?
M: Like-
39: I think I'm the reason why cavemen painted on walls. Gehhehuhu
*confused mark*
M: What does that mean? What do you mean by that?
M: What does that mean?
M: What are you talking about?
*kids shout YAAAAYYY*
M: Oh who's a grumpy guy?
M: Ooooh, I don't like that!
M: BwwaaaAAAHHH, that's a bad!
M: Alright, hang on. I'll just keep goin' then.
M: Alright, I'll keep goin!
M: I'll see what happens!
M: Night two, Oh, hey, how's it going? You holding up your ears to be two fingers?
39: So, you've come back for more, eh? You know I could just keep on doin this. M: uh-huh
39: I honestly dunno why, but I seem to have fun running around a pizzeria every night
*beep* tripping over ladders, *beep* cursing and everything *mark laughs quietly*
39: Honestly, I may be kinda retarded
39: You know, like a *beep* kid, you - you know they *beep*
39: Heh
39: *laughing* Thank god that's censored! Everyone would have my head if they knew what I just said!
39: Anyway! (M: Oh boy...) I'm in a more hyper mood tonight and I'm bound to get more hyper throughout every night. So...
39: You know, same deal as last night, just a little bit faster
M: A'riight-
39: I don't know what the point of all this is again.
39: Anyway
39: Goodnight
M: Yeah, I don't know what the point of it either is! Cause a-again, can't see shit!
M: Nothin' to see!
M: Nothin's happenin'!
M: Boo!
M: Boo~
M: *strange noises*
M: BLINGBLONG! Oh it's already one AM! Man, the nights go so quick! I love it!
M: I can just sit here and reLAX!
M: Blibbliblaiib
M: Blaauugh
M: WwuuuaaaAAAHHhh
M: Uuhaah
M: UUhhaaAAAHHHhh
39: This is the part where I drain power to make things very intense! M: Okay!
M: Alright then, goodbye! Have a good one!
M: Blipblah! This can't be all there is, right?
M: There's gotta be more to this than just this!
M: Blipblahblib-bleh-bliblAHBLIBBLIB
*Bbang* *39 laughs evilly*
M: Okay, alright then. What was that all about?
M: Alright, I guess I'll just... wander here in my loneliness...
M: Thinking about all my past accomplishments of kicking Animatronics asses
M: You know I have a crown?
M: It's pretty cool right? I know, you're jealous.
M: Jealous of how cool I a-
39: BAH! *mark jumps*
39: Gotchyaaa
M: Fuck, dude! BOINK!
39: *whimpers/cries*
*mark mocks 39s cries* Big bubble blowin' baby over there!
M: EAH! I just realised I'm sc- I'm screaming at a doorway
M: AAH
M: HEY! YOU THERE?!
M: COME OUT AND SAY HI~!
M: MY NAME IS MAARK-iplier
M: I HAVE A YOUTUBE CHANNEL
M: LI-
39: BAH
39: Gotchyaaa
39: BAH! Gotchyaaa. *mark laughs*
M: What's the point he comes in anyway! *39 whimpers* He comes in anyway!
*39 still whimpering*
What's the point?!
M: You messed up my monologue!
M: MY MOM PLAYED FIVE NIGHT'S AT FREDDY'S O~ONE
M: SHE HAD A LOT OF FUN!
M: SHE CALLED YOU FREDDY
M: SO COME AT ME BRAH! IMMA FIND A WAY TO STAB YOU IN THE EYE!
M; REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED TO BONNIE IN FIVE NIGHT'S AT FREDDY'S TWO?
M: WHOLE HEAD RIPPED OFF!
M: IMMA DO THAT TO YOUR BUTT!
M: IMMA RIP YOUR BUTT ALL THE WAY OFF!
M: AND SHOVE IT DOWN YOUR HEAD!
M: YOU GONNA HAVE AN ASS FOR A FACE!
M: I WANT FANART OF THAT TO MAKE IT REAL!
39: This is the part where I drain power to make things very intense M: EEUGH
M: Oh no, I'm sorry!
M: I'm sorry about that. Did I hurt you? I apologize.
M: Anyway!
M: I'M GONNA TEAR OFF YOUR ASS!
M: YOU KNOW HOW IN FIVE NIGHTS AT FREDDY'S TWO
M: YO- I HAD TO WEAR FREDDY'S HEAD?
M: YOUR GONNA HAVE TO WEAR YOUR OWN ASS!
*bang* *39 laughs evilly*
M: Nice, I'm very spooped about that
M: DO YOU KNOW HOW SPOOPED. I. AM?
M: Vvvery
M: YOU KNOW I'M-I'VE SURVIVED A LOT OF INCARNATIONS FROM YOU
M: I DON'T THINK YOUR TOO THREATENING. I WAS EVEN YOU IN ANOTHER GAME
M: Remember Bonnie simulator?
M: That was like, that was another one of those, like, really funny
M: Uh, Five night's at Freddy's fan-games
M: Like, I LOVE the funny ones! Just because it pokes fun at it!
M: But in a good way! It kinda pays homage to the original one.
M: It's-it's just a li'l silly! And I like this bite-sized piece of silliness here
M: Alright, I win! Yeah, gimme my award! I know, just come on, gimme my award. I'm good, I'm not even gonna bother doin' anything else
M: Mmm
M: Vodka!
M: *whispers* It's not, I'd die, it's water
M: Alright, what's goin' on?
M: How you doin?
M: Yeah, see, now I'm debating if I even need to press your nose because I- I think I'm gonna win.
M: You just gonna stand there? Lookin' like a grumpy Gus?
M: Huh? Oooh, shakin' my head! Oh! Too late! Oh! Didn't win!
M: Oh no, sorry about YOU! Sorry about how much you suck!
M: I know you were born with it, but it's just, I - I still feel bad. *kids cheer YAAAYYYY*
M: WOOAAAHH! I'M A GRUMPY GUS! WOOOAAHH I HATE MY JOOOB
M: Hey, how you doin? How you doin over there? I see you!
39: Okay, is this becoming a thing now? Is this like a *beep* Five Night's before Freddy's *beep* *beep*
39: I mean come on maaan
39: D-don't make me I have to put up with you for another three nights? *mark laughs*
39: Even though it'll actually turn out to be another two nights, cause, y'know, Scott Cawthon really *beep* you over that way
39: Seriously, I'm...(spit it out 95% of us do.)
39: Starting to get a bit tired of you, man. But, I'm still in a pretty hyper mood. So I'm gonna be even more active tonight.
M: Oh good!
39: *beep* you. I mean.
39: And I'm sick of you touching my *beep* nose too!
39: Really pisses me off!
39: Eugh
(I think mark was going to say something but ok)
39: ...I feel like I'm cute in this pose, don't you reckon? Yeahaha!
39:I feel like I'm cute in this pose,dont you reckon? Yeahaha!
(Awkard scilence hi how was your day?)
M: What the fuck was that?
M: What are you talking about?
M: Can I actually see something on the camera's now? NOOOO.
M: What kinda pose are you cute in and why did you repeat it?
M: Is that supposed to be a cluu-
39: *trips* Ooohh! *beep* on the bloody thing!
M: *laughing* Did he trip over something?
M: Is that what he did? He tripped over something?
M: Oh boy, I am sitting through all five nights of this!
39: Aboogeywoogeywoo~ Mother *beeeeep*
*Mark laughs*
39: Aaawah! *unintelligible noises ...darn you... *high pitched* Don't touch my nose *whining*
*39 whining* M: Aboogeywoogeywoo~ Mother fumper
M: Oh no my-
39: Ah *beep* on the bloody thing, I lost my *beep* glasses
*happy, silently giggling Markimoo*
*Giggling Markimoo*
M: DANANANAAAAOM
M: NO ONE IS THEEEEERE
M: No one is there, no one is there, NO ONE IS THERE!!
M: NO ONE IS THERE
M: NO ONE IS THERE!!
M: YOU
M: AAAAAAARE
M: That woulda been good if that would actually happen
M: HUAAH! Okay nope.
M: BAH! Alright, fine then, I'm just screming for no reason- BWAAAH
M: Alright then, fine. Your just making a FOOL OUTA ME
39: OH OH *beep*! OOUF! *beep*... That. Really. Hurt. *Marki laughs*
M: You alright buddy?
39: BAH
39: Gotchyaaa (M: Awahyowahahaa) BAH! Gotchyaaa
*Mark laughs* Aboogeywoogeywoo~ Mother *beeeeep*
M: Awwwwe, your curse word got interrupted by the bonk!
M: Welp!
M: We got to six AM with absolutely nothing happening!
M: I took a sip a water and then we're here
Oh, ishe gonna be Grumpy again? Oh, oh is the bunny gonna be a little grumpy bunny? Oh no, life is hard you have to have responsibilities.
M: Okay, fine then.
M: Night 4
Hi then!
hi there.
Well i guess this IS going to be that cash-grab
*bleep* piece of *bleep* series...
Five Nights at Freddy's...
Just a couple more nights, you're really starting to
get to me man. I mean jeez.
So what? I...So what if i killed your son?
I mean, that's what we possessed animatronics do,
Because for some reason when children are murdered, and they are put into *bleep* animatronic
suits that become murderous! IT MAKES SO MUCH *bleep*-ING SENSE DOESN'T IT?!?
*39 Laughing*
Yeah!
OK I literally cannot think of anything else to say. I'm gonna be more active, as always.
I really should stop telling you that every night because you basically know the *bleep*-ing drill.
*SIGH*
It's just... *bleep* you Sam!
Oh I'm Sam am I? I'm Sam. Apparently I am Sam.
I thought I was Eggs Bonderbick Bischnebatch. (wtf?)
....dabbing. I think I've just got terminal cancer.
You are the one dabbing on the MAIN MENU!
This is the part where i drain power to make things very intense.
*BONK*
UNGH!
Oh!
*Whining and complaining*
Oh no oh no go cry about it.
DAB your tears away. (GET IT HAHA IT'S SO FUNNY)
BLOOGEYWOOGYWOO! Mother *bleep*
Little Moron... *Bonk* NO!
DON'T TOUCH MY NOOSE!
So, are you gonna be so active that i gotta
actually pay attention here because that seems like
bullshit to me ( pause)  i dont wanna have to do that
A BOOGY WOOGIE WOO! MOTHA *Bleep*
Wasn't paying attention, were you doin somethin?
Oh 4444! Knight 4, 4 am
44 percent left- thats nice
I always live for these moments..
I'm gonna make a w-uhh it's 43 percent, i cant make a wish now..
I  CAN WISH FOR YOU TO GO AWAY!
*BONK* OH IT WISH WOKED
*39 whimpering in the background* My wish came true guys!
ain't that nice?
I love- YAYYY WE DID IT!
I WASN'T PAYING ATTENTION (I can tell)
Alright! Good to know!
I- I have a feeling
It's gonna get to point where
he's just there so much
that theres no way to win, theres no way to PREVENT HIM.
OBVISOUSLY! Thats not a thing that happens...
But, uh, yeah!
It's just, it is what it is...
oh, come on, night 5! whaddya gonna
say about me, sassy sue! Come on!
bring it on! I'M READY for- *39 sex scream*
Last night, I had to put up a deal
sh**taking more Saam...
Man, this calls
for a celebration.. I have
written down a few insults
I'd like to share with you right now M: Bring it on I'm ready!
I'm insult man! ( Sure..) I;d help you
drown in the stagnent, *bleep* hole
You good for nothing *Bleep*
Yep, yep that was one...
F**k YOU with a RAKE!
uhh. heh. khh
dosen't make sense, but, it's pretty good...M: Which end?
I mean it could make sense 39: I will
f**k you so brutally, that your
kitchen will REAK for MONTHS!
I don't how I will get the F**k out of this place...
and I really dont wanna f**K you...
Yeah... M:I- I -I didn'.. Gimme some
Credit, mate, come on,..
OH YEAH! and my
last one,  suck a pound of putrid d*cks.
...and...
thats basically, it all from now
and I'm so f**king excited! Cuz I'll be able
take this F**King sensor off thats been *bleep*
bothering me for the past 5 *Bleep*NIGHTS!
AH *Bleep*
*Bleep*
*LONG BLEEP* (Mark breaking into laughter)
hah, the sensor will be going tomorrow..
I can do what i like, you can *bleep*off
let's end-
this mate. M: YAYYYY!!!
LETS DO IT, HORAYYY!
FINAL NIGHT!
May-bee, we'll see how that goes..
Hey how you doin there? Hows the nose? 39: UNH!
Mark: Good? Cool, You stay you buddy, you stay you...
Now why are there multiple letters here
Might as well move them...OH!
F**K F**K F**K!
OH DAMMIT! DAMMIT!
*Bleep* DAMMINT C**NT!
SOME OF A *Bleep*
Mark: Soorryyy... Are you there???
BLALALALALALALALLALAHH
COME ON IM BORED...
NO your not even there
Your not even there to spoop me.
Is there anything on the monitors?
Noooooo....
I. Feel like your. Not.
Particarpating in this conversation.
HELLOO.
Nope. Not there again. Look,
If you wanna learn
39: (Wierd voice) Uaaaahhh Look at me.
I'm Foxy, Yiff the fox!
39: (Normal) You sick *Bleep*s.
*Markimoo Giggle* Okay, Alright.
Ya know I feel like dialogue has broken down here.
You need to actually listen to your
FEELINGS
deep inside
I know that deep inside
is the... dead child. (Mark Why?)
(M):But ignore that for a second here and just...         (39): ABOOGYWOOGYWOO Mother *Bleep*er
(M):Just CONNECT with your inner feelings, man.
(M): 39 or Bonnie or whatever are
Or whatever that is
or whatever you wanna be
Because you can BE whatever you wanna be!
(Iron Giant reference Mark?)
Just come talk to me, man!
Feel so lonely! );
(39): ABOOGYWOOGYWOO Mother *Beep*er
(M): Oh thats not talking to me
Thats just talking AT me.
(M): *whispering* You need to listen.
With your ears *pokes eyeball out*
(39): I wish I could make things right... );
*Markimoo with disbelief in his natural habitat*
(M): Well that was...
That was weird.
Are you here to apologize?
I like dialogue is actually starting now.
*BUZZ* Come on! Talk to me
Continue, you can make things right *really?*
I mean you can't bring my dead son back.
But come on! Try!
*Ominous appearance by 39*
(M): He wants to say something!
*BONK!* Ugh, man. Just while I got feel
where we were getting somewhere
HE RUNS AWAY!
And hides his GIGANTIC UGLY NOSE *Do you take offense 39?*
and RUNS AWAY!
*Grudge*
LISTEN TO YOURSELF!
(M): Gonna say something?
(39): Ugh! (M): OOH!
*More complaining from 39*
(M): You can do it.
Take as many times as you need.
I Believe in you *That's mean Mark!*
*Ding Dong*
(M): Allright, I guess were done here then.
Uuuhgood bye!
I wonder if there, if there is a 6th night. Isn't there.
OOOHHH GRUMPY I'M NOT IN TOUCH WITH MY EMOTIONS. (;/
BEE BOO. Alright, K'mon!
Wudda ya got?
(39): AAnd now, the torture comes to an end.
I get to take my censor off and go with my life
And you can get to FUCK OFF
(M): OOOOOOOOOHHHHH!!!
(39): and go on with your life (M): Noice!
(39): So Let's end it...
Right here.
*Ta* Catch ya later mate!
(M): OKAY! (39): Ohoho. And if you come back...
You will be sorry.
(M): Alright!
Ooh i'm, I'm gonna come back!
Hey! Dabby Mc. Dabberson!
Let's Let's have another go! Cmon! I don't wanna wait around for this!
IM BACK UHBAEBEE!
You gonna make me, sorry, WARNING!
EXTREMELY OFFENSIVE CONTENT!
You heard! Oh.
*39 havin' a fap party!*(Mark is surprised and then in disbelief)
(39): Oh Fuck Yeah!
*Giggly Bitch Markimoo!*
(39): Oh I missed you...
*Markimoo giggles and 39 ghasps*
(39): WHAAAAA OH FUCK
OH!
WHAT THE FUCK ARE YOU DOING HERE!
*giggly Mark*
(39): YOU SON OF A BITCH!
I THOUGHT YOU WEREN'T COMING BACK! *PFFT*
UAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHH!!!!!!
*Mark laughs uncontrollably*
That's it. That does it. I've got a few things to say to you,
MATE!
DIE, IN AN OCEAN OF FIRE
YOU PISHEABLE CUNT! *what?*
(M): Ooooohhhhh...
(39): I'm sure you want to suck my anus, you grungy,
shit.
Run along and gargle a beaker of Cocks-Milk
You son of a bitch!
*Mark Giggles Shamelessly*
(39): You have leprosy,
Don't worry though,
The news isn't all bad;
You're also going to die!
Wallow in a ocean of anal puss *ewww*
You pisheable SON OF A BITCH!
Ahaha,
It will be more than allright if you shut your fucking cry-hole!
you senseless Barrel of Dicks!
*Creams Self*
I said that just in case you were crying
I don't want you around here,
Even your closest friends don't want you around
Perchance it would be the best for everyone if you threw yourself off the tallest building you could find!
I have heard that they wish you would die.
So.
DIE!
Sam Clydeson!
Fucking hell!
(M): Sam Clydeson? (39): You know what? Fuck it!
I'm Coming For You! *That's What She Said!*
Man. YOU ARE FUCKED!
(M): Okay, Alright then.
Come at me, Bro! *BONK*
I don't know if i'm gonna have enough power by the end of this,
But You know I'll Try!
I don' I think your gonna drain me dry! *Euphamism?*
(39): ABOOGYWOOGYWOO MOTHER FUCKAA! *Mark Giggling unrelentlessly!*
*BONK*
(M): I Sorry, I interrupted your private session with your body pillow!
I'll let you get back to your...
Uhhh... Hentai Animangas
eh in the near future
Just bear with me for a few more seconds as I try
to uh (39): ABOOGYWOOGYWOO MOTHERFUCKA (M): get to know you. Who you are
As a person!
That's what ive here for, that's what ive been trying this whole time man!
...Been trying!
Trying real hard! );>
I know You have been REAL hard but...
Listen...
... Its not about that.
Yeah i'm pretty sure this is setup for failure. A:\
I'm pretty sure the only way to get through this is to lose all your power
and die because you walked in on him while he was... *SHEEEE*
MASTURBATING TO A BODY PILLOW!
Thats so sad for him but either way, so, I, I think this is gonna end and when he kills me.
There's gonna be something "good" at the end? Maybe
Maybe?
(39): This would have been so much better, but you had to go with someone else.
(M): Hmm
Now I Don't know what that means,
"Things could have been so much better but you had to go with someone else.
Me?
Me had to go with someone else?
Or you, She had to go with someone else?
I couldn't understand that. (39): Do you even lift Brah?
I, I, I lifted your nose off your stupid face.
Yeah, Its not gonna work.
*Shit*
(M): OH NO! (39): Hey! Who turned out the lights? *Trips* OOF! Ooooh... Oooh... I think I broke my nose.
*Mark Scoffs*
FUCK
(M): Ya gonna...
(39): If your expecting the Toriador March
You have another thing coming....
Jumpscare in 2
WUUUAHHH
*Giggly Mark*
Okay
I don´t think there is anyway to win that
because I just don´t think there is enough power left
It could be like a random thing where you're just like
randomly maybe win that but
I don´t think it's worth it an-a*stumbles in words* (please finish it mark ;-;)
I think it´s what you know, I honestly didn´t think I could go through the whole game
like this, but I like this a lot!
It was pretty funny
I would- any Five Night's at Freddy's fan
don´t take it too seriously, obviously
I-I-I-It´s nice to just make fun of, every once in a while
This guy awfully *mutters* This character is supposed to be an asshole
A-a-a-and that's fine!
So anyway, thank you everyone soo much for watching
if you want to play for yourself and
maybe night 6 is beatable (ofc it is, you nee to be more lazy Mark)
I don´t know, I just don´t have the willpower to try to beat it (says the king of fnaf)
Because I have just been sit here waiting
and enjoying the show *outro musics fades in*
So, thank you everyone soo much
there will be the link in the description
And as always!
I will see you....
In the video!
Bye-Bye~
*playing outro music* *subscribe to Markiplier by clicking his face in the bottom right corner*
*And check out the other videos at the left bye have a nice day :)*
*music turns off*